Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Quanti di voi si ricordano
un episodio dove hanno provato stupore?
Sì, è vero, richiede qualche minuto
per andarlo a pescare nella memoria.
Nella mia mente, se ci penso,
scorgo un ricordo nitido.
Avevo circa cinque anni
e mi trovavo con mio nonno
che lavorava in un piccolo sgabuzzino,
in giardino, in una giornata di sole.
Mio nonno era sempre là,
falegname, ormai in pensione,
schizzava disegni su fogli
e "Sara, questo va lì, Sara questo va là",
sapeva creare modellini
di macchine, congegni, orologi, velieri
e altre cose che accendevano
la mia fantasia!
Sapete che effetto fa far vedere,
a una bambina come ero io,
creare uno di questi congegni?
Ve lo dico io: ha un effetto dirompente!
Un mese fa ho festeggiato i nove anni
dall'uscita del mio libro
"Automation and Robotics - Automazioni
e Robotica di Leonardo da Vinci".
Questo mi ha portato lontano,
in terre, luoghi e sensazioni,
e dato più di quanto una ipoteca
sulla felicità possa mai fruttare.
Chi di voi ha letto Asimov?
Io, durante la mia adolescenza,
ne ero innamorata
e sognavo un mondo pieno di robot.
Avevo ancora negli occhi mio nonno
che, ancora troppo piccola,
vedevo creare, ideare, modificare
e infine realizzare dei pezzi unici.
Il legno, l'odore del Vinavil,
il suo sguardo attento
e operoso dietro gli occhiali,
e poi tutta una serie di fogli,
su cui ruotismi, ingranaggi,
leve, molle e balestre
avevano la meglio sugli scarabocchi
e sui suoi tentativi
e al contempo scrivevano la mia storia.
Sì, perché ancora non sapevo
che quella sarebbe diventata
la mia vocazione,
grazie a saper sviluppare
questa capacità straordinaria
di sapere che cosa
c'è schizzato sopra un foglio,
sia esso stesso realizzato 30 anni fa
oppure 500 anni fa.
Poi io ho incontrato lui,
il professor Carlo Pedretti,
che era, è, e sarà per me per sempre
il più famoso studioso
di Leonardo da Vinci.
Partito da Bologna,
con una passione irrefrenabile,
con una precisione chirurgica
per il metodo e il rigore del lavoro,
e una capacità straordinaria
e indiscutibile
di ricomporre e studiare
le carte di Leonardo,
arrivò da giovane a Los Angeles e da lì,
in tutti i testi a cui
uno studioso si deve avvicinare
se vuol conoscere,
e poi successivamente approfondire,
lo studio di Leonardo.
Adesso sono specializzata
nella automazione e nella robotica,
nei congegni idraulici e pneumatici,
nell'orologeria, nei teatri,
nella meccanica statica
e dinamica di Leonardo.
Fu proprio sua l'idea,
del professor Pedretti:
"Dai Sara scrivilo,
questo libro sulla robotica!
Scrivi quello che ti sembra di vedere!
Fammi vedere!"
Vi faccio vedere.
Da un punto di vista tecnologico,
gli "automata",
dalla parola greca automàtos,
che si muove di propria volontà,
possono essere definiti
come l'esito più alto raggiunto dall'uomo
nella gara di mimesi con la natura.
Essi sono dei veri e propri miracoli
di ingegneria meccanica
che erano stati proprio creati
per destare meraviglia e stupore
per le corti dei signori
più potenti del tempo.
In questa definizione, "automata",
o se vogliamo,
secondo l'antichità classica,
"simulacra autocinetici",
rientrano dei robot, degli automi,
che quindi riproducevano
le fattezze umane e animali,
ma anche tutti i congegni più complessi,
come per esempio fontane,
congegni idraulici,
pneumatici, orologi e teatri.
Una delle prime menzioni
del termine "automata"
addirittura la ritroviamo
nell'Iliade di Omero;
nel testo, infatti, si racconta
di operai specializzati e robot
che si muovevano liberamente,
quindi da soli,
nella magica fucina di Efesto,
non a caso dio del fuoco,
dei metalli e della tecnologia.
E sapete che l'esito più alto
fu raggiunto
dalla scuola alessandrina,
in particolar modo con la figura
di Erone di Alessandria,
che accanto a congegni
molto più complessi,
come, per esempio,
quello di poter spalancare da sole
le porte di un tempio,
andava a ricreare dei robot
che si muovevano sfruttando
la pressione dell'aria sull'acqua.
Sappiamo poi che la conoscenza
dell'antichità classica,
nel campo della robotica,
passò poi al mondo arabo.
In particolar modo, la summa
della conoscenza della meccanica araba
ci viene tramandata dalla figura
di un inventore, astronomo e artista,
Al-Jazari,
di cui si hanno notizie
tra il 1136 e il 1206.
Ora, proprio nel 1206
abbiamo il suo libro sui dispositivi,
sui fantasiosi, meravigliosi,
dispositivi meccanici,
nel quale sappiamo dell'esistenza
di una cosiddetta "fontana del pavone",
una sorta di dispenser di acqua e sapone.
Oppure della favolosa "nave dei musici"
che, capace di librarsi e muoversi
su uno specchio d'acqua,
poteva ricreare una sorta
di vera e propria melodia,
grazie a questi robot musici
muniti di strumento
per allietare magari
i sontuosi banchetti del tempo.
Bene, facciamo un salto nel tempo
e arriviamo a Milano.
1482, Leonardo arriva
alla corte di Ludovico il Moro.
Anche l'ambiente milanese era un ambiente
ricco di stimoli
e di eccellenza tecnologica.
Giovanni Fontana, una sorta di inventore,
fantasioso, una figura poliedrica,
fu il padre di questa,
della cosiddetta "strega infuriata",
una sorta di creatura ibrida
meccanica, semimovente,
dotata di coda di serpente
e ali di pipistrello
che sbucando fuori all'improvviso,
perché mossa su alcune rotaie,
poteva destare sicuramente paura,
ma anche meraviglia.
E poi era anche il padre
del "diavolo meccanico"
una sorta di antecedente
di questo bellissimo e meraviglioso
"diavolo ligneo", capace di muoversi,
che è conservato alla collezione Settala
del Museo del Castello
Sforzesco di Milano.
Anche Leonardo, nel 1492,
si misura con questo compito,
cioè quello di disegnare
quello che dagli studiosi
era stato definito un "automa cavaliere".
Questo progetto viene ad essere schizzato
su vari fogli del Codice Atlantico,
che voi sapete conservato
nella Veneranda Biblioteca
Ambrosiana di Milano.
E in particolar modo,
il foglio più importante
è questo, il 579 recto,
nella quale appunto Leonardo studia
questo complesso sistema
di carrucole e di ingranaggi.
In particolar modo,
grazie a questi quattro dispositivi,
proprio nel 2010, nel mio libro,
avanzavo l'ipotesi
di poter leggere questo
cavaliere automatico come un tamburino,
quindi vale a dire un musico,
dotato di un tamburo melodico,
che potesse in qualche modo scandire
il ritmo delle feste e dei balli,
ma anche le entrate ufficiali
alla corte degli Sforza.
Questa mia intuizione
ha ricevuto una menzione speciale,
in un articolo, su Scientific American,
intitolato "I, robot",
fatto da un ingegnere della NASA,
che si è complimentato
e che ha decretato
questo successo della mia intuizione.
Da un punto di vista tecnico,
questi studi di Leonardo
sulla meccanica e sugli automatismi,
sui robot,
determinavano l'incontro,
e forse anche lo scontro,
tra gli studi del campo
dell'anatomia e della cinetica.
Egli veniva pertanto a tracciare
una sorta di "anathomia artificialis"
in cui il corpo umano
era paragonato a una macchina.
Egli stesso, a un certo punto,
va a definire il corpo umano
come una macchina meravigliosa,
perfettamente congegnata.
E quindi, pertanto, si assiste
a una sorta di vero e proprio parallelismo
tra gli organi come ingranaggi
e il corpo come macchina.
Lo stupefacente "leone meccanico", invece,
fu un'allegoria politica,
fatta sfilare davanti
al nuovo re di Francia Francesco I
a Lione nel 1515.
Sappiamo che fu commissionato a Leonardo
dai facoltosissimi banchieri fiorentini
di stanza a Lione,
e doveva rappresentare
una sorta di vero e proprio
grazioso dono diplomatico,
fortemente politicizzato a questo punto,
e che andava a sancire
una sorta di strettissima alleanza
tra Firenze e la Francia.
Questo leone viene a essere studiato
soltanto in questo foglio,
appartenente al Codice di Madrid,
ma abbiamo delle testimonianze:
infatti, Giovanni Paolo Lomazzo,
nel 1584, ci dice:
"Una volta dinanzi a Francesco,
primo re di Francia,
fece camminare da sua posta, in una sala,
un leone fatto con mirabile artificio,
e poi fermato, aprendosi il petto,
tutto pieno di gigli e diversi fiori".
L'unica testimonianza diretta, invece,
è una testimonianza posteriore,
scritta da Michelangelo
Buonarroti il giovane,
nipote del ben più famoso Michelangelo,
contemporaneo di Leonardo,
che ci descrive le nozze
tra Maria de Medici, di Firenze,
e Enrico IV, allora re di Francia.
E dice:
"Nella testula della tavola di mezzo
di quelle gentil donne,
per colmare la meraviglia,
in aspetto fiero un Leone ebbe,
che posando su quattro piedi,
allora che a tavola elle si misero,
prendendo moto, e sollevandosi in due,
aprirsi il seno si vide,
e pieno di gigli mostrorlo.
Concetto simile a quello,
il quale Leonardo da Vinci,
nella città di Lione,
nella venuta del Re Francesco I,
mise in opera per la nazion fiorentina".
Questo giovane osservatore
ci va a sottolineare
che già nel 1600,
quindi molto dopo rispetto
al primo congegno di Leonardo,
si perpetuava in Francia ancora
il ricordo della tecnologia vinciana
attraverso un leone
di più piccole dimensioni,
che però si muoveva
sopra questo banchetto nuziale
e andava incontro agli sposi.
Rispetto a tutti gli automi
dell'antichità,
questo di Leonardo è il primo automa
che non sfrutta soltanto
una fase meccanica,
ma addirittura ha un programma interno,
che sfrutta fasi meccaniche
in diverse fasi di tempo.
E ne ho individuate cinque.
Dunque, il Leone meccanico
era capace di muoversi
da un punto di vista tecnico,
attraverso lo sgancio delle balestre
e lo svolgimento delle molle.
Poteva colmare una distanza molto ridotta,
dai 3 ai 5 metri massimo.
Poi un meccanismo interno
determinava, quindi,
che il leone si alzasse a sedere
sulle zampe posteriori,
e si riattivava un meccanismo
simile alla prima fase,
in cui si apriva una sorta
di vero e proprio sportellino, dal petto,
ed erano capaci di ricadere, al suolo,
in omaggio al re, dei gigli.
Il giglio, naturalmente,
aveva un grandissimo valore
politico e simbolico,
era un'allusione alla città gigliata
per eccellenza, cioè Firenze
e pertanto anche al fleur-de-lys francese.
In questi studi Leonardo
va quindi a riflettere
come potete immaginare,
sul tema del movimento,
della trasformazione del mondo naturale,
e va a tracciare quello che,
secondo una straordinaria definizione,
si può descrivere come una sorta
di "meccanica dell'universo".
E quindi, accanto al volo degli uccelli,
che lui studia nel Codice del Volo,
conservato alla Biblioteca Reale a Torino,
non potevano mancare
gli uccelli meccanici, volanti,
che potevano librarsi in aria
come un giocattolo
nelle mani di un bambino.
Io so che ognuno di voi, ora,
mi vuol fare la domanda della serata:
ma Leonardo è stato a Bergamo?
Sì!
Sappiamo che Leonardo
conosceva benissimo le valli lombarde,
in particolar modo,
le studiava per la loro idrografia
e per ragioni strategico-militari,
ma tutte le volte
che l'occhio del cartografo
incontra l'occhio del naturalismo,
si hanno questi disegni meravigliosi,
che non sono soltanto
una restituzione del territorio
ma descrivono letteralmente il territorio.
Ogni cartografia,
ogni schizzo cartografico,
è in Leonardo un'opera d'arte.
E quindi vediamo
come in questo primo disegno,
anch'esso conservato,
come gli altri due che vedremo
alla Biblioteca Reale a Windsor,
quindi nelle collezioni della Regina,
vediamo la Val Brembana
e poi, oltre la linea obliqua,
la Val Trompia e la Val Sabbia.
Vediamo che Bergamo è identificata
con questi due piccoli cerchi,
che corrisponderebbero
quindi, come mi insegnate,
ai due luoghi insediativi,
della città bassa e della città alta.
Poi abbiamo uno studio
del bacino dell'Oglio,
e in questa carta la cosa curiosa
è che tutti i paesi
che si ergono sulle sponde del fiume
sono scritti in dialetto bergamasco,
e questa è una prova
che lui stesso era in questi luoghi.
Molto spesso - voi non lo vedete,
ma sono molto piccoli -
ci sono le distanze che intercorrono
tra villaggio e villaggio
e quindi hanno una prova
di presenza sul territorio.
Poi abbiamo anche la valle del Serio,
dove ritroviamo la città di Bergamo,
invece qui identificata
soltanto con un cerchio,
appunto per andare
a identificare la città,
che quindi si ergeva alla fine
di questo tragitto d'osservazione
molto importante.
Quello che io ho appreso
durante tutti questi anni,
e di cui vi ho dato
un velocissimo scorcio,
una piccola parte,
è stato proprio quel sentimento
di non perdere mai
questo sentire straordinario,
che sono riuscita a imparare
accanto alla migliore persona
che potevo mai avere
da 500 anni a questa parte,
il professor Pedretti;
e anche dalla possibilità
di non perdere mai la curiosità
che mi ha sempre caratterizzato
fin da bambina.
La scoperta:
è questo che ancora mi emoziona.
E il desiderio di farla,
di mettermi sulla sua scia, di acciuffarla
è proprio la molla
che muove gli ingranaggi del mio cuore.
Grazie.
(Applausi)